legend is the word that pertains
pertains to sean connery in the business
around long enough
that's what happens it's nice though
isn't it that's very nice
yeah wonderful
it's easy to see why connery was one of
our most enigmatic stars
at once a charismatic leading man who
could turn a pulp hero into a global
icon
[Music]
james bond and a reluctant celebrity who
distanced himself from hollywood's
publicity machine
even at his own movie premieres are you
all excited
well yeah sort of in a way in fact
connery's rise to stardom was accidental
born dirt poor in edinboro scotland in
1930
he lived in a rough neighborhood worked
as a milkman and joined the royal navy
at 16.
two years later he discovered
bodybuilding and everything changed
i came down to london the mr universe
contest i was
a weightlifter then during the time i
was there they had
auditions for south pacific so i went
along and
told them i was an actor and
sung a few bars and anyway they bought
it
connery never looked back and within a
few years he had earned a reputation as
a charmer
on screen and off what is it to know
except that i love you in 1957 rumors
about a fling with co-star alana turner
reached her gangster boyfriend johnny
stompanato
who flew to the london set in a rage gun
in hand
as the story goes connery laid him out
cold with a right hook
[Music]
a year later walt disney himself chose
connery to play a singing irishman
and brought him to california oh she is
my dear mud island one her eyes so
sparkling full of fun
but shawn felt upstaged by the special
effects
little did he know super stardom was
just a martini away
chicken not stirred although bond
creator ian fleming didn't think he was
right for the role
connery remains the ultimate james bond
for many fans
but after six movies he was convinced he
wasn't being taken seriously as an actor
and began to resent agent 07 saying i'd
like to kill james bond
when i was doing the bond films it was
difficult to
convince most people that one would want
to do other things
i was quite sure for me anyway that it
was going to be very very limiting
in the early 70s he walked away from the
role and sought more prestigious
projects
like the oscar-nominated murder on the
orient express
robin and marion with audrey hepburn and
one of his personal favorites
the man who would be king i'm heartly
ashamed for getting you killed instead
of going home rich like you deserve to
on account of me being so bleeding high
and bloody mighty
the 1975 adventure teamed him with his
best friend michael kane
for decades they were inseparable and
often the subject of wild hollywood
tales
one story claimed kane calmly held
connery's coat as shawn single-handedly
beat up four men
in a bar a story he never denied i've
never had a press agent
and consequently i never had a way
to handle the the onslaught of the press
and the
media that you work for connery actually
could have used a good press agent
consider his infamous 1987 interview
with barbara walters
you think it's good to slap a woman no i
don't think it's good i think
it must i don't think it's that bad i
think that it depends entirely on the
circumstances and if it merits it
where do people see this interview are
you gonna get male
i might get some female you carry a
badge
yes carry a gun connery did get hate
mail
but all seemed forgiven just a year
later when he received his first
oscar nomination for playing a tough
irish cop opposite kevin costner in the
untouchables
he pulls a knife you pull a gun he sends
one of yours to the hospital you send
one of his to the mark
that's the chicago way and that's how
you get capone
e.t was with him after the nominations
were announced he was worried his temper
would get the best of him if he lost
as i am not that certain how my
responses are
i wouldn't be able to guess what my
respirator probably wouldn't clap i
don't know
sean connery
i don't know why they never gave me an
oscar for james bond
you would have to ask them whoever they
are how did you know she was a nazi
she talks in sleep the oscar propelled
connery into a career renaissance
and e.t was with him as he made a
seemingly endless series of hits
a great day comrades we sail into
history
when he invited us to scotland for
entrapment in 1999 we found the 69 year
old still embracing the part of dashing
rogue
we're also going to meet catherine
zeta-jones she's going to talk to us
she's something else isn't she catherine
cheetah charles did you find what you're
looking for
and that was the secret to conrie's
lasting appeal his charisma
seemed ageless after all this is the man
people magazine called
the sexiest man alive a year before his
60th birthday i met a gentleman last
night who said that you give
new hope to bald men everywhere oh god
yes i was wondering what about bald
women
you